uh  [Music]  that  what  was that the noise coming from a dog  this is sickening to me just because  he's putting his paw  on something that doesn't mean that he's  choosing to wear it okay this is  something we always do we we ascribe  human intentions to to to animals  it's one of the reasons why people  always say oh look at the dolphin in the  ocean  jumping around he's so happy  look he's smiling no his mouth is just  like that he can't help it all your dog  he's a dog he wants to run around and  the fur god gave him that's what your  dog wants wants to do you hear me you  wacko pet owners i don't even like  animals and i'm the one sticking up for  their rights here these these people are  going to turn me into a pita activist  for too long